I guess because I'm from Tanzania have a
responsibility to welcome all of you
once again thank you for coming so first
of all before we start how many of you
in the audience have been in the past a
victim of this bug here we apologize on
behalf of all the mosquito catchers
ladies and gentlemen imagine getting
seven infectious mosquito bites every
day
that's 2555 infectious bites every year
when I was in college I moved to the
Columbia River Valley in southeastern
part of Tanzania this is historically
one of the most malaria zones in the
world at that time life here was
difficult in its later stages malaria
manifested with extreme seizes locally
known as dengue dengue it killed both
women and men adults and children
without mercy my home institution if
acara Health Institute began in this
valley in the 1950s to address priority
health needs for the local communities
in fact the name if acara refers to a
place you go to die which is a
reflection of what life used to be here
in the days before organized public
health care when I first moved here my
primary role was to estimate how much
malaria transmission was going on across
the villages and which mosquitoes were
transmitting the disease so my colleague
and myself comes 30 kilometres south of
Africa a town across the river every
evening we went into the villages with
flashlights and siphons we rolled up our
trousers and waited for mosquitoes that
were coming to bite us so we could
collect them to check if they were
carrying malaria my colleague and myself
selected the household and we start
inside and outside swapping positions
every half hour and we did this for 12
hours every night for 24 consecutive
nights we slept for four hours every
morning
watch the rest of the day sorting
mosquitoes identifying them and chopping
off their heads so that they could be
analyzed in the lab to check if they
were carrying malaria parasites in their
blood thoughts this way we were able to
not only know how much malaria was going
on here but also which mosquitoes were
cutting this malaria we were also able
to know where the malaria was mostly
inside houses or outside houses today
ladies and gentlemen I still catch
mosquitos for a living
but I do this mostly to improve people's
lives and well-being this has been
called by my some people the most
dangerous animal enough which
unfortunately is true but what do we
really know about mosquitos it turns out
we actually know very little consider
the fact that at the moment our best
practice against malaria air bed bears
insecticide-treated bed nets we know now
that across Africa you have widespread
resistance to insecticides and these are
the same insecticides the pyrethroid
class that are put on these bed nets we
know now that these bed nets protect you
from bites but only minimally kill the
mosquitoes through this year what it
means is that we've got to do more to be
able to get to zero and that's part of
our duty at Bacara Health Institute we
focus very very much on the biology of
the mosquito and we try to do this so we
can identify new on opportunities a new
approach new ways to try and get new
options that we can use together with
things such as bed nets to be able to
get to zero and I'm going to share with
you a few examples of the things that my
colleagues and myself do that this for
example mosquitoes breed in small pools
of water not all of them are easy to
find they can be scattered across
villages they can be as small as hoof
prints they can be behind your house or
far from your house and so if you wanted
to call control mosquito larvae it can
actually be quite difficult to get them
what my colleagues and I have decided to
do is to think about what if we used
mosquitoes themselves to carry their
insecticides from a place of our choice
to their own breeding habitats so that
wherever whichever eggs they lay there
shall not survive
this is Dixon Louetta gerrae this is my
colleague who runs this shorty ficarra
and he has demonstrated cleverly that
you can actually get mosquitos to come
to the place where they normally come to
get blood to pick up a dose of a set of
sterilants or insecticide carry this
back to their own breeding habitats and
kill all their progeny and we have
demonstrated that you can do this and
crush populations very very rapidly this
is beautiful this is our mosquito City
it is the largest mosquito farm
available in the world for malaria
research here we have large-scale
self-sustaining colonies of malaria
mosquitoes that we rare in these
facilities
of course they're disease-free but what
these systems allow us to do is to
introduce new tools and test them
immediately very quickly and see if we
can crush these populations or control
them some way and my colleagues have
demonstrated that if we just put two or
three positions where mosquitoes can go
pick these little substances we can
crush these colonies in just three
months
that's Auto dissemination as we call it
but what if we could use the mosquito
sexual behavior to also control so first
of all I would like to tell you that
actually mosquitoes made in what we call
swamps male mosquitoes usually
congregate in clusters around the
horizon usually after sunset the male's
go there for a dance
the females fly into that dance and
select a male mosquito of their choice
usually the best-looking male in their
version they clump together and fall
down onto the floor if you watch this
it's beautiful it's a fantastic
phenomenal this is where mosquito
catching a built-in work gets really
interesting what we have seen when we go
mosquito hard so I'm hunting in the
villages is that this swarm locations
tend to be at exactly the same location
every day every week every month here in
years they start at exactly the same
time of day evening and they are exactly
the same locations what does this tell
us it means that if we can map all these
locations across villages we could
actually crush these populations by just
a single blow
kind of you know bomb spray them on
nuclear mouth and that is what we try to
do with young men and women across the
villages we organize this cruise we
teach them how to identify these swamps
and spread them out my colleagues and I
believe we have a new window to get
mosquitoes out of the valley but perhaps
the fact that mosquitoes eat blood human
blood is the reason they are the most
dangerous animal on earth but think
about it this way mosquitoes actually
smell you and they have developed
incredible sensory organs they can smell
from as far sometime as 100 meters away
and when they get closer they can't even
tell the difference between two family
members they know who you are based on
what you produce from your breath skin
sweat and body odor what we have done at
if a car is to identify what it is in
your skin or your body or your sweat or
your breath that this mosquitoes like
and once we identify these substances we
created a concussion kind of a mixture a
blend of synthetic substances that are
reminiscent of what you produce from
your body and we made a synthetic blend
that was attracting three to five times
more mosquitoes than a real human being
what can you do with this you put in a
trap you Lou a lot of mosquitoes and you
kill them right and of course you can
also use it for surveillance at if acara
we wish to expand our knowledge on the
biology of the mosquito to control many
other diseases including of course the
malaria but also those are the diseases
that mosquitoes transmit like dengue
chikungunya and Zika virus and this is
why my colleagues for example we have
looked at the fact that mosquitoes like
some mosquitoes like to bite you on the
leg region and we've now created this
mosquito repellent sandals that tourists
and locals can wear when they come in
and you don't get bitten this gives you
round-the-clock protection until the
time you go under your bed my love hate
relationship with mosquitoes continue
and it's going to go a long way I can
see but that's okay wh you a set a goal
of 2030 to eliminate malaria from 35
countries the Africa Union has
a girl of 2030 to eliminate malaria from
the continent if acara we are family
behind these goals
and we put together a cohort of young
scientists male and female who are
champions who are interested in coming
together to make this vision true they
do what they can to make it work and we
are supporting them we are here to make
sure that these dreams come ladies and
gentlemen even if it doesn't happen in
our lifetime even if it doesn't happen
before you and me go away I believe that
your child and my child shall inherit a
world free of malaria transmitting
mosquitoes and free of m'lady thank you
very much ladies
thank you okay ladies let's talk about
CRISPR for a bit
it's taken the world by storm it
promises to do amazing things what do
you think of scientists using CRISPR to
kill off mosquitos I think to answer
this question let's start from what the
problem is so first of all we're talking
about a disease that still kills
according to the latest figures we have
from wahe of four hundred and twenty
nine thousand people most of these are
African children of course we've made
progress there are countries that have
achieved up to 80 60 50 60 percent
reduction in malaria body but we still
have to do more to get to zero there is
already proof of principle that gene
editing techniques such as CRISPR can be
used sufficient and effectively to
transform mosquitoes so that either they
do not transmit malaria we call this
population alteration or that they no
longer exist population separation this
is already proven in the lab there is
also modeling a work that has
demonstrated that even if you were to
release just a small number of these
genetically modified mosquitoes that you
can actually achieve elimination very
very quickly so CRISPR and tools like
this offer us some real opportunities
real life opportunities to have high
impact interventions that we can use in
addition to what we have now to
eventually go to zero this is important
now of course people always ask as well
with a common question I guess you're
gonna ask this as well what happens if
you're living it was heated okay well in
respect to this I would just like to
remind my colleagues that we have 3,500
mosquito species in this world maybe
more than that about 400 of these are
Northlands and only about 70 of them
have any capacity to transmit malaria in
Africa we are having to deal with three
or four of these as the major guys okay
they carry most like 99% of all the
malaria we have if we were to go out
with gene editing like CRISPR if we were
to go out with gene drives to control
malaria we would be going after only one
or two I don't see
versity problem with it but that's
personal view I think it's okay and
remember by the way all the year we've
been all these years we've been trying
to eliminate these mosquitos effectively
by spraying them our colleagues in
America have sprayed with you know
really bomb spraying these insects out
of the villages in Africa we do a lot of
house household spraying all these are
aimed solely at killing the mosquitoes
so there's really no problem if we had a
new tool but having said that I have to
say we have us also have to be very very
responsible here so there's the
regulatory side and we have to partner
with our regulators and make sure that
everything that we do is done correctly
it's done responsibly and that we also
have to do independent risk assessments
to just make sure that all this
processes do not fall into the wrong
hands thank you very much thank you
[Applause]
[Music]